-Our next guest is a
Grammy-winning, Tony-nominated
actress you know from shows
like "Modern Love,"
as well as the films
"The Wolf of Wall Street"
and "Palm Springs."
She stars in "The Resort," which
is streaming now on Peacock,
with new episodes
premiering Thursdays.
Let's take a look.
-[ Breathes deeply ]
Estoy caliente.
What the [bleep]
does this guy want?
-Oh, yeah, yeah, you can just...
-Oh [bleep]
Oh, my God.
[ Ringing ]
Pick up your phone.
Pick up your phone,
pick up your phone.
[ Cellphone vibrates ]
-Hey. Emma, hey. Where are you?
-Don't look for me.
Don't look for me.
[Bleep]
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Cristin Milioti.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Cristin.
I'm so happy you're here.
-I'm so happy to be back.
Thanks for having me.
-In the beginning of that clip,
you said, in Spanish --
You were trying to say,
"I'm hot."
-That I'm hot.
-But you said, "I'm horny."
-Yeah, they cut off
the first part,
where I'm clearly
in a wool blanket
in, like, a tropical location,
and then I say, "I'm horny,"
instead, by accident.
-Is that indicative of your own
Spanish-speaking skills?
-It's -- It is.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. We -- That was, like --
We had been all hanging out
at the beach during the weekend,
and my co-star,
Luis Gerardo Méndez,
who is brilliant on the show --
he had been teaching
me and my other cast member
Nina Bloomgarden
phrases not to say.
And one of them
was "estoy caliente,"
which just means, "I'm horny."
But you'd think it would
mean that I'm hot.
And so I did it
to make everyone laugh.
Like, make the crew laugh.
We were shooting in like
a 200-degree fruit market.
But they kept it,
which is, like, a delight.
But, also, it made sense,
because I think that she
also wouldn't know Spanish
and she would also
be like, "Oh, I'm horny."
-This is a fantastic show
with you
and William Jackson Harper.
He's a wonderful actor.
-Oh! Who I love.
-And you're on a
10-year wedding anniversary
and you go to a resort, and then
you start investigating
a decades-old murder.
-That's right.
-This is, like, a very fun idea.
-Yeah, well, you'd think,
but hijinks ensue.
And that's the thing
that they don't see coming.
-Yeah, they always --
Almost everything you're in,
hijinks do, in fact, ensue.
-Oh, I don't -- I get --
Yeah, I don't go anywhere
where there's
not hijinks, apparently.
It's like, not by choice, but --
-Yeah. They follow you.
-They follow me. That's true.
Yeah.
-They pursue.
The hijinks pursue.
-That's right. Hijinks pursue.
-You filmed in Puerto Rico.
-Yes.
-Which must have been
incredibly beautiful.
How did you find it?
-Wonderful.
How did I find it?
I took a plane there.
-Yeah.
-And then --
-And that's something, like,
the airlines do, right?
-And they took --
Much to my surprise --
-You buy the ticket,
but they, like, find it.
-Yeah. And I was like,
"Do you guys --" Exactly."
Yeah, I was like, "You guys know
how to find this or --"
And they were like, "Ma'am,
get out of the pilot's cabin."
Yeah. And I was like,
"Can I also have a drink?"
No. I don't know.
That's, like, a stupid old joke.
Pilots don't drink.
-Oh, my God.
-Smash. Good night.
Yeah, no, they found it for me,
and then I got there.
And I really liked it.
It's a brutal place to shoot.
-Yes.
-I mean, I feel silly
ever being like,
"Oh, the shooting was so --
It was hard."
Like, it's an incredible job,
but, yeah, every day is
like 100 degrees.
-Shooting in nice,
air-conditioned places is hard.
-It's great. Totally.
-No, like, they're long days.
-They're long days. And -- Yeah.
But we were, like, in the
jungle, 100 degree every day,
our incredible crew
pushing, like,
giant cranes up mudslides.
We would have to hold for rain
because it was
a literal rainforest.
And giants bugs --
-So that's on you.
-So that's actually on us.
And you're right about that.
-When you go to a rainforest,
you're like, "Ugh, rain."
-Yeah, and I was like, "Rain?"
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. This is false advertising.
-Did you come
right out of quarantine
and go into shooting the show?
-Oh, yes.
-Yeah.
-So, when I landed in
Puerto Rico,
I was tested for COVID and then
went to go visit the set
and kept my mask on
because I was feeling, like,
a little weird, even though
we were shooting outside
and I thought it was because I
had just been on a plane.
And, like, sure enough,
20 minutes later,
they were like,
"Oh, you have COVID.
Right this way."
And they put me in
a hotel room for 12 days
that I wasn't allowed to leave.
And it was very dark, and I
faced off with my shadow self.
And then we were back. Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, it's incredibly --
-I mean, that's another thing
where you think like,
"Oh, if you're going to be in
a hotel for 12 days,
it's got to be Puerto Rico."
But I bet even the beautiful
views make no difference after
like the first six hours.
-Well, because -- Yes.
Also because the hotel
I was in --
We all lived in apartments.
But, you know,
for the first couple days,
I landed at this hotel
that was above a casino
and is, like,
known for bachelorette parties.
So, I was, like, upstairs like
the little kid in
"The Secret Garden."
And, like, they --
There were, like, you know,
drunk bachelorettes on the beach
being like, "Whoo, Kimberly!",
and then, like, a deejay on
the beach just playing,
like, the same song by
The Weeknd.
If I hear "Blinding Lights"
by The Weeknd one more time...
Like, I already started to turn
into, like, a Gotham villain
in that room, where I just was
like -- Like, you just --
You're -- It's 12 days
not leaving a single room.
I would, like, look outside.
I would peek out the window,
like, all drawn,
in, like, a white,
sweaty bathrobe from the hotel.
-I like to think that there
were bachelorette parties
going to the front desk
and complaining about this woman
who was, like, peeking out.
"We're trying to have fun,
and there's a dead woman."
-Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
-"There's a ghost of
a dead woman."
-"This place -- We weren't told
this place was haunted
when we booked it on
Groupon or whatever."
Like -- Yeah, I, basically,
just would, like,
glide into view and glare at
them while, like,
shaking violently
and coughing into my arm.
And the TV was broken.
I could only watch this one --
Then the TV was broken, Seth.
Oh, my God.
-We all had
really hard quarantines.
-It was crazy. Yeah.
Oh, that sounds terrible.
But the TV was
broken, so I could only watch
"A League of Their Own"
over and over and over again.
And so, I was -- Which I love
"A League of Their Own."
But I was just crying
all the time, like,
in a bathrobe, sweating.
-This is great.
I mean, so your nightmare right
now would be
The Weeknd opening for
"A League of Their Own."
-Exactly. I would be, like --
[ Gasps ]
Like, just -- Yeah.
I would start shivering.
-We've talked about your
desert work in films such as
"Palm Springs," and now you're
doing some jungle work in this.
-That's right.
-Do you have a preference
of where to shoot?
Because they both seem,
like, pretty...
-Intense?
-...trying, yeah.
-Yeah. The jungle.
I like the jungle.
-Oh, okay. That's nice to hear.
-I like it.
I love a tree.
No, but I do. I love...
[ Laughter ]
It's beautiful.
There's so many great smells.
There's -- Yeah.
-What a sales pitch.
Do you -- Does the --
-Yeah. You guys are going to
love the jungle.
If you like smells
and rain and bugs and mud,
you are going to love
the jungle.
But I actually --
I really do like the jungle.
The desert I don't trust.
-Yeah.
-Why are we out there?
We don't belong there.
That's like when
we're in a plane.
Why are we up there?
We don't belong there.
We're not birds, Seth.
I don't have to tell you.
-You don't have to tell me.
I've been saying that
from the beginning.
I was the first guy
who noticed, remember?
-I forgot. That's right.
You were like, "Wait a second.
Wait. No."
Yeah. No, but, yeah,
the desert feels like that,
when, like, there's no water.
It's hot.
We're not --
Even lizards have trouble here.
-Yeah.
-Why are we here?
-Right. Anybody who's thriving
in the desert looks super-weird.
-Looks weird.
Spiders underground.
-Yeah.
-Spiky shrubs.
-No, thank you, spiky shrub.
-No, thanks. Yeah.
-I'm barely okay
with normal shrubs.
-That's right, yeah.
If I've said it once,
I've said it a thousand times --
I don't mess with
spiky shrubs anymore.
-Yeah. And, obviously, you don't
want to be messed with
or else you wouldn't
have evolved into being spiky.
-Thank you. So why are we here?
-Yeah. Well, I think we've made
our case against the desert.
-Yeah. Yeah.
I'm proudly coming out as
anti-desert.
-You definitely are. Probably?
-Yeah. Dusty.
-Well, that's enough?
-Do you love sand in your eyes?
-Some people in the desert
watch this show. Enough.
-Well, I have a --
Yeah, I have...
I do have questions about
living in the desert,
but we don't have to
get into it now.
-Maybe next time?
-Okay.
-Alright. It's this the
best having you here.
Thank you so much.
-I love being here.
-You guys,
that's Cristin Milioti.
"The Resort"
is streaming now on Peacock,
with new episodes
premiering Thursdays.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."